one time I think I was watching one of
your lectures or maybe from a
conversation before and you said that I
have no idea why the sporadic groups are
there and then I was wondering like why
do the sporadic groups need an
explanation like what would an
explanation look like this goes back to
our earlier question of the Moonshine
conjecture like what does it mean to
explain to me like why is it not as
arbitrary as saying I don't know why the
number is 7000 and 300 exists or why are
there five platonic solids
as part of we would like to understand
them um so so if you take the Compact
lead groups
um we have a classification of them that
you mentioned earlier you know there's a
and b and CN and
E8 and things like that and there we've
got a very simple explanation of why
this list turns up
um that they more or less correspond to
finite reflection groups and we know how
to classify finite reflection groups and
understand them very easily and
um
this allows us to give a we can give a
single uniform construction of all the
Compact lead groups
um but there's nothing like that for the
spread it groups
um I mean we we can sort of copy what we
did for compact groups and for that we
find
most of the finite simple groups
um we find all the all the ones of lead
type but then there are these 26 left
over which just don't fit into this
pattern and it's very frustrating
because what we would like is some
uniform way to construct all the finite
simple groups
and what really worries me is that maybe
we already have the correct way to
understand warwicks is to go through
this 20 000 page proof of the
classification and we're and and we're
simply too stupid to understand why why
this is the correct explanation